[Music]
Kim Kardashian and Northwest are making
the most of maternity leave the
Kardashian West family just grew a
little bit bigger with the arrival of
Kim and Kanye's fourth baby a little boy
born via surrogate and while they
haven't revealed a ton of details about
the bundle of joy
Kim is giving fans a look into what
she's been up to since his birth and
apparently it's making a music video too
little nods x's old town road with her
five year old daughter
[Music]
yep that's North E getting down to some
sick beats the 38 year old shared the
masterpiece on Twitter explaining it was
directed and choreographed by North the
costume the lip-synching the dance moves
oh my Kim also gave a close-up of
North's outfit on her Instagram story
talk about commitment she seems to have
decorated it herself with the words Old
Town Road written on it
[Music]
[Music]
of course this isn't the first time
we've seen little north bust-a-move
in march Kim shared this video of
North's stealing the show at her dad's
Sunday service how cute is this
daddy-daughter moment though and while
it looks like North might be taking
after her rapper dad Kim told et in 2018
that her little girl might just follow
in her footsteps
is she a beauty mogul in the making will
she take over for you one day
you know I actually had to put her on
our PR list and get her her own set of
makeup this time because she destroys
all of mine when she sees it and then I
can't use it for myself so she she
definitely loves makeup if she loves it
enough she can definitely take it over
whatever she wants to do when she is old
enough she can do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]